my name is Winston Duke and I play Gabe
Wilson and Abraham and us I'm gonna be
reading some first tweets preface this
was someone else's idea and boku could
blow my em back out if we wanted to I
like but you did them back out - oh
thanks Thank You Justin go out eat with
some Dukes ass like an almond joy I want
to cook him breakfast and I hate cooking
Wow well is this gonna make it on air
whoa sorry these what I get these you
guys chose these you guys you're you're
sick Winston Duke is a fine thick piece
of paint like a Renaissance Fair turkey
leg
I want a bite wow that was creative that
was creative I've been called many
things but a Renaissance Faire turkey
leg not one of them thick piece of meat
I've heard before
I just want to spoon Winston dudes fine
Scorpio six for ass is that Ariana
Grande no it's not I was like are we I'm
out here in these streets listen
Winston Duke could literally rip me in
half and my spirit would thank him thank
you that's a kind spirit Winston Duke is
the kind of man I need the kind of man
that can pick you up with ease and wrap
your legs around his shoulders a strong
feminist I think that's that better I
don't know if that's usually what
defines a strong feminist but thank you
for the recognition it's been almost a
year since I decided I'd let Winston do
crush my skull between his thighs and I
just want you all to know that nothing
has changed and I still mean every
syllable well thank you for the offer
uh we really thought about crushing any
heads between my thighs but like I'm
glad to know I have the option I would
birth Winston Dukes children no
questions as many as he wants I'm gonna
be pregnant for ten years straight
that's a lot of pregnancy
it took me two days to build up the
nerve to watch the us movie trailer and
let me just say this how dare you at
Jordan Peele
how dare you take my fantasy of true at
Winston Dukes and turn it into something
horrible that's cute
that's not bad that was a really thirsty
that was more supportive the us trailer
terrifying
Winston Duke in these dag glasses and
comfy clothes threatening people with a
baseball bat
dreamy a F thank you that yeah that's
really sweet that's not that thirsty
that's not that thirsty
you could thirst more Winston Duke isn't
even a snack he's a four-course meal and
a dinner mint oh thank you thank you I
like that one
I want Winston Duke to hug me so hard
that he shatters my ribcage that's low I
would consider myself an excellent
hugger haven't shattered any rib cages
recently xxx BuzzFeed after the dark out
here so what part of Twitter did you
guys find me he went looking for these
pills bucket
[Music]